[Music]
[Applause]
he is not human he is catastrophic
there's nobody playing better in the NBA
right now the karl-anthony towns there's
another Pro by Teague
[Applause]
it's rated the rim to be on the key to
come right in the face
man that was nasty yes
[Applause]
smoke moves by karl-anthony towns
see why they're talking about here at
Minnesota why he's should be Rookie of
the Year
[Applause]
one over a bead one a pie karl-anthony
towns look at envy goes for it
footwork pump fate one dribble you want
some come on over there young fella
karl-anthony towns thankfully no worse
for wear goes right back to work
[Applause]
is Affairs jammed don't poke the bear
you rock the rim on that one it's still
shaking down there
Oh v I totally know
[Applause]
brought it down with authority
kliklak welcome to your Kodak moment my
friend will you sign this poster for me
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
spatula there was nothing that was going
to stop the hurricane that is
karl-anthony towns so what a great
chance ten-millionth on the left in the
finish with the right pocket
here comes tea last year with the
indiana pacers towns
[Applause]
boy we offer to you some unbelievable
plays here at the rim cat karl-anthony
towns running the floor
how about the finish over ere and bein
gross back to town season opening crow
Anthony towns just slices it take that
Paul let us say what a tape Jones took
Butler
like that oh I don't think it is Center
in the league you know innocent a run
with him no not really
what up at your boy Adam left codes you
like that content I know you like that
content hit subscribe for more of it
from Bleacher Report